abrazos y lágrimas de alegría así
recibió una multitud a las afueras de un
tribunal de georgia la noticia de que
tres hombres blancos fueron condenados
por asesinar al mundo árabe en febrero
de 2020 dentro del recinto el juez
anunció que greg mcvay con su hijo
travis mcmichael y su vecino william
brady bryant fueron hallados culpables
de asesinar a abril mientras corría por
el vecindario los acusados lo atacaron
después de que uno de ellos denunciara
que un hombre afroamericano que portaba
un arma se veía sospechoso
al principio nunca pensé que este día
llegaría a decir verdad nunca había este
día en 2020 ahora que es al que conoces
como ahmed y yo lo conozco como que es
ahora va a descansar en paz y volar
tras una deliberación que se prolongó
durante 10 horas el jurado determinó que
suavice mcmichael fue responsable de
nueve cargos incluido el de asesinato
malicioso del cual fueron declarados
inocentes 'break' mcmichael y brian una
decisión que llevó al presidente
estadounidense a hacer un reconocimiento
al sistema de justicia
nada puede traer al señor albert y de
regreso a su familia y a su comunidad
pero el veredicto asegura que aquellos
que cometieron este horrible crimen
serán castigados para muchos el caso de
harvard y es un ejemplo de la injusticia
racial en eeuu una acusación que tendrá
que pasar por un juicio federal en
febrero donde se determinará si el
asesinato de arví tuvo motivos raciales